So, we saw in the previous
video that the house prices
were distributed over the
area in an interesting way,
certainly not the
kind of linear way.
And we wouldn't necessarily
expect linear regression
to do very well at
predicting house price,
just given latitude
and longitude.
We can kind of develop
an intuition more
by plotting the relationship
between latitude and house
prices-- which doesn't look
very linear-- or the longitude
and the house prices, which
also looks pretty nonlinear.
So, we'll try fitting it in
a linear regression anyway.
So, let's call it latlonlm.
And we'll use the LM
command, linear model,
to predict house prices based
on latitude and longitude using
the Boston data set.
If we take a look at
our linear regression,
we see that r squared is
around 0.1, which is not great.
The latitude is not
significant, which
means the north-south
differences aren't
going to be really used at all.
Longitude is significant,
and it's negative.
Which we can interpret as,
as we go towards the oceans--
we go towards the east-- house
prices decrease linearly.
So this all seems
kind of unlikely,
but let's work with it.
So let's see how this
linear regression
model looks on a plot.
So let's plot the
census tracts again.
OK.
Now, remember before, we had--
from the previous video--
we plotted the
above-median house prices.
So we're going to do
that one more time.
Median was 21.2.
We had-- the color was red.
And we used solid dots.
Ha.
Oops.
See what I did there?
I used the plot command,
instead of the points command,
and it plotted just
the new points.
I meant to plot
the original points
and use the points
command to plot it
on top of the existing plot.
OK.
So that's more like it.
So now we have the median values
with the above median value
census tracts.
So, OK, we want to
see, now, the question
we're going to
ask, and then plot,
is what does a linear regression
model think is above median.
So we could just do
this pretty easily.
We have latlonlm$fitted.values
and this is what the linear
regression model predicts for
each of the 506 census tracts.
So we'll plot these on top.
Boston$LON-- take all
the census tracts,
such that the latlonlm's fitted
values are above the median.
Take the latitudes, too.
And I'm going to make them blue,
but let's pause for a moment
and think.
If we use the dots again,
we'll cover up the red dots
and cover up some
of the black dots.
What we won't be
able to see is where
the red dots and the
blue dots match up.
You know, we're
interested in seeing
how the linear regression
matches up with the truth.
So it'd be ideal
if we could plot
the linear regression blue
dots on top of the red dots,
in some way that we can
still see the red dots.
It turns out that
you can actually
pass in characters
to this PCH option.
So since we're
talking about money,
let's plot dollar signs
instead of points.
And there you have it.
So, the linear regression
model has plotted a dollar sign
for every time it
thinks the census
tract is above median value.
And you can see
that, indeed, it's
almost as-- you can
see the sharp line
that the linear
regression defines.
And how it's pretty
much vertical,
because remember before,
the latitude variable
was not very significant
in the regression.
So that's interesting
and pretty wrong.
One thing that
really stands out is
how it says Boston is
mostly above median.
Even knowing-- we saw it
right from the start--
there's a big
non-red spot, right
in the middle of
Boston, where the house
prices were below the median.
So the linear regression model
isn't really doing a good job.
And it's completely
ignored everything
to the right side
of the picture.